until this video came out to actually
prove it we didn't know exactly how they
were transporting these uh illegals from
one point to the other but the american
people do not want these people
in their neighborhoods and this is
something that joe biden has snuck
around it's illegal and i do expect
congress to hold him accountable
calls for joe biden's impeachment begin
following the release of footage
exposing secret flights of illegal
immigrants being released in suburban
american towns under the cover of
nightfall fox news contributor trump
joins us now laura one former president
was impeached in the house over a phone
call shouldn't this president be
impeached over actively facilitating the
destruction of our sovereign border
yeah i mean you would think that that
would be enough let's see what happens
here look one of the most basic
functions of a president is to secure
our borders here in america and we know
that the biden administration
has failed every single day at doing
that we had millions of people come into
this country illegally
last year alone that would be enough to
impeach a president they have done
everything but invite people to come to
america illegally but then todd to see
these flights to see that under the
cloak of darkness in night there are
charter flights which by the way is a
very nice way to travel the guy in this
video actually said wait i have to take
my shoes off when i get on a plane and
these people just get to walk on their
charter flights to west chester new new
york and then they get on buses and the
buses don't even tell the police officer
here where these people are going this
is unconscionable this was done on
taxpayer money so not only is joe biden
allowing people to come to this country
illegally he's been flying them all over
america bussing them all over america
the people of america are paying for
this to happen so yes i would think if
anything you would be able to find some
way to call up for impeachment here and
you know what it is not a victimless
crime you know people say well we want
to help these people you guys reported
earlier in the show over 250 million
lethal doses of fentanyl have crossed
our southern border under this
presidency that's exactly right
yeah the drug issue is a big deal and
the fact that cartels are making money
off of this is another huge deal we've
been playing footage all morning uh this
body camera footage that shows a dhs
contractor who was working this flight
that um landed at westchester airport
and illegal immigrants were let out in
new york this body camera footage shows
him even questioning the strategy listen
to this
i get the whole secrecy and
and also laura we learned that there
were 14
people on the terror watch list that
were caught at the southern border last
year and then you just have to wonder if
those people were caught how many got
through and how safe are we in this
country right now
well you know you guys have talked all
morning about um an officer down in
texas being killed by a person who was
an illegal immigrant with a rap sheet
you know you talk about the fentanyl i
just mentioned coming into america the
gangs coming into america this is so bad
for our country everyone that lives in a
border state has felt the impact of this
and now it is being felt all across
america because these people are being
flown and bust everywhere in our country
and todd you mentioned it earlier the
fact that donald trump got impeached
over a perfectly acceptable phone call
yes joe biden should be impeached over
this very thing this is a failure on
every level to stand up and do your duty
as president of the united states and so
many people at this point say it must be
purposeful how else could you allow two
plus million people that we know of to
come into america illegally
fly and bust them all over the country
if it weren't on purpose this is
unbelievable and has to stop we are
going to lose our country if we don't
get this under control if i'm the
republicans
i highlight this in every single
campaign ad between now and november and
say come january 2023 we're going to
look into this and an investigation will
lead in all likelihood to an impeachment
of president biden lara trump have a
great weekend we always appreciate you
getting up with us enjoy
thank you laura thanks guys i'm steve
ducey i'm brian kilmeade and i'm ainslie
earhart and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis